from the east coast of the vale the
fingers reach out into the narrow sea
four rocky peninsulas plagued by wind
and rain and barren to all but the
hardest of weeds
the ancestral home of house baelish
our house began with my great
grandfather a bravosi cell sword who
came to the veil at the invitation of
house corbre
my grandfather raised himself to the
status of hedge knight and even managed
to acquire a bit of land and a keep on
the smallest of the fingers though i do
believe he often missed sleeping under
his titular hedges
the only thing worse than owning a
dreary and desolate land is owning only
a small portion of it
luckily i didn't spend much time there
as a child
during the war of the nine penny kings a
cheap name for a cheap cause where other
men fought for the king my father fought
to befriend hoster tully lord paramount
of the trident and head of one of the
oldest and greatest houses in westeros
thanks to my father's heroic efforts
lord hoster agreed to foster me at
riverrun with his own children
until then my whole world had been a
small tower on the gull stained rocks of
the fingers but when i first saw the
stone walls of riverrun rising from the
trident towering over me
back then i was a little more easily
impressed
the boy in me thought the gods
themselves must live in such a place
i soon learned otherwise
lord tully's son edmure was quick to
ensure i would never forget myself in
their house
he nicknamed me littlefinger after my
size and homeland and the name was just
cruel enough to stick
his sisters
lysa and catelyn made me a pawn in their
kissing game
traded back and forth between them for
practice
needless to say i enjoyed spending time
with them more than edmure
and as we grew older the game began to
change as all games do
liza grew more bold and cat more demure
when lord tully announced cat's
betrothal to a brood from the north whom
she'd never met i realized her duty
would outweigh any feelings she had for
me
fool that i was i challenged this
brandon stark to a jewel for her hand
he was a warrior i was a boy
if cat had not intervened he would have
killed me and laughed over my corpse
before my insolence lord tully banished
me from riverrun
no matter i had learned everything i
needed by then
i would fight my battles not with swords
but with wits a few men could match me
even then house baelish might have died
out on the rocks of the fingers
i was again a poor lord with no allies
and no prospects except if i were lucky
the daughter of a middling merchant
then opportunity arose
the mad king executed that brandon stark
and incited a rebellion
my old friend lysa tully was married
after john aaron lord of the vale to
cement the alliance against the iron
throne bringing her within my circle
again
i quickly capitalized on our former
affection and persuaded her to have me
appointed as controller of customs at
gull town the vale's greatest port
wars burn gold like wildfire
when i increased the port's income
tenfold her husband took notice of this
lowly lord from the fingers and when the
new and profligate king robert needed a
master of coin who could find gold where
no one else could why lord aaron knew
just the man
honor
glory
lies to make idiot boys want knighthood
an idiot girl spread their legs for it
let me tell you what makes a knight
killing
either enough men
are the right man
house clegane should know we're very
good at both
most families claim some great ancestors
so far back that nobody can prove them
lives
not us
my grandfather kept the kennel for lord
titus lannister of casterly rock
the father of lord tywin
lord titus was a weak man who didn't
know it
one day while hunting he stumbled on a
lioness
instead of embracing the man who wore
her on his banners
she tried to tear out his throat
lucky my grandfather came up with the
dogs
and drove the big cat away
as a reward the cleganes got lands and a
keep and a son to squire for the
lannisters
we took the three hounds who died for
them as our new sigil
when tywin lannister became lord of
casterly rock he wanted more from his
former kennel master than fealty
he bet the training hounds to kill isn't
far from training boys to kill
in just two generations my brother
gregor and i proved him right
i gutted my first man at 12
years after
seven started disappearing in our keep
and even a sister i don't remember
but nobody could prove anything against
gregor
or dared if they caught him at it
for my father wanted a night in our
family
and thought he'd found one in gregor
who had 13 towered over enough men that
they called him the mountain
sure gregor looks quite the champion
from a distance
but a mountain can't cleave a man in
half with one blow
and won't break a winch's face if she
talks
through lord tywin's influence prince
rhaegar targaryen kindly anointed my
brother personally
a great honor for her family everyone
said
one year later
sir gregor shiversly sacked the prince's
city brained the prince's baby and
murdered the prince's wife winning our
family yet more
honor from the new king and queen
soon after my father died
they say in a hunting accident
the same day that gregor became lord of
the clegane lands gold and anything
under his roof i left our home to take
servers at castle rock
lord tywin is not like his father
neither is king joffrey
or the likes of me would never be on the
king's guard
with all those true knights
between them
a man who serves the lannisters
will never lack for killing
i'll guard this king
such as he is
gregor will kill the other ones such as
he does
when we're done
we'll see how many people still believe
in songs and fairy tales
where house reed holds the gate to the
north house mandalay holds the port
white harbour the closest thing to a
southern city we have governed by the
closest thing to a southern family we
have generations ago the mandalas were
driven from the reach but the starks
gave them their land in return for
failty
now white harbour is the richest city of
the north and the mandal is the richest
family
not in gold and silver like their
southern counterparts but in fish grain
and trade
as for the other great northern houses
the starks brought them into the fall
during the age of heroes
a stark wrestled nineborn for bear
island and gave it to the mormons
a stark granted a keep and land to a
younger son carlon in return for putting
down a rebellion
his family then grew up into the car
starks
starks fought the wildlings and their
kings beyond the wall beside the umbers
of last earth thus earning their failty
boltons
but then they were the bane of the north
a few were even rumored to wear their
enemies flayed skins as clarks
but after centuries of war
they too bent the knee
roderick stark wrestled an ironborn lord
for bear island and granted it to house
mormont when he won
a younger son of our family carlon stark
won his own keep after he put down a
rebellion and founded house karstark one
of the most powerful in the north
when the mandalees were exiled from the
reach my ancestors shielded them and
gave them a home at the mouth of the
white knife in return for holding the
river against pirates and invaders
now they're one of the wealthiest houses
in the north
i'm not so naive to pretend that the
entire north welcomed stark rule
the last war king was slain at sea
dragon point along with all his sons and
beasts
the last marsh king died at the hands of
king rickard stark and house reed has
held the swamps of the neck ever since
houses greenwood towers amber frost
none survived today as more than names
in dusty old books
but my ancestors never wanted to destroy
their foes root and stem
the umbers of last half and the glovers
of deepwood mot bent the knee and became
loyal vassals of house stark
the red kings of house bolton wore
cloaks made from the skins of stark
princes they flayed and one of the
boltons was even known as the red arm
because he liked to plunge an arm into
the bellies of captive starks and pull
out their entrails with his bare hand
the north deserved to be wiped clean of
them
yet my ancestors spared them after their
defeat because they believed the north
couldn't afford to fight itself any
longer
time soon proved them right
when the andals swept into westeros they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the
first men except the north
each of the southern kingdoms fought the
invaders on its own but the north fought
as one
when the andals tried to sail up the
white knight the mandalas fell on their
ships
when the andals tried to march an army
through the neck the reeds fell on their
soldiers